do you think that that is a good look
for the Republican Party look what we
told Democrat leadership when they went
down this this pathway of removing
members from committee is basically
saying you should not do that because if
it's good for the goose it's good for
the gander let's be very clear Elon Omar
has said things that are reprehensible
to hold on hold on hold on let me finish
we should not be going down this pathway
of saying oh that member said this they
got to be kicked off of committees that
is happening no no no no no no we're not
what we're doing is she said you did it
so now this is what happens this is the
response let's get back to the status
quo of you pick your committee people
we'll pick ours and we'll go from there
we just want to change the rules and
we'll live by your rules I don't think
we should do that but if you want to
change the rules that the House of
Representatives has lived under since
the beginning of the Republic and now
you're going to change them because you
didn't like what somebody said he knows
exactly what he's talking about and he's
got receipt